it's a little more than 100 miles
outside the capital
but several different armed militia
gathered despite the heightened security
and worries of violence ahead of
wednesday's inauguration
these are the boogaloo boys
anti-government
fervently pro guns and proud to admit
they have a certain power
because of their weapons as a as an
outsider looking in you've got all these
different groups
with different affiliations and
different allegiances
all tooled up wearing you know quite
heavy
machinery um it doesn't look
like the the best sort of foundation for
peace all right so for us to peacefully
protest
without any infringement from the police
department
when we show up these things aren't they
really don't mess with us
if we come out here unarmed they've
shown a history of
doing things they shouldn't be doing six
feet
a couple of streets away we found the
black panthers circling the state
capitol building which has been sealed
off in case of attacks
this militia equally heavily armed were
keen to impress how persecuted they felt
for years
tell us a little bit about your fears
about the far-right extremism
in america i mean as a foreigner looking
in
that seems to be a big issue here the
thing about i just can't reiterate is
being a black man in america any type of
fear there's no type of fear that we
haven't experienced every single day of
our lives like this has literally been
our
our reality our entire lives so right
now this is nothing new they're not
saying anything new to us
the militia appear to have different
ideology and sometimes none
and there's a clear rivalry and distrust
between them
how divided
um not necessarily hopefully not
tell me what you think the problem is
ma'am if i could um
if i mean we can continue the talks once
we get where we're going we're heading
to uh eighth abroad what is it you're
worried about though
proud boys are not yeah no they are
definitely not uh
individuals we want to associate with
virginia's state capital was fenced off
and streets
shut down pro-gun activists descended on
richmond once the capital of the
confederacy during the u.s civil war
they want looser gun laws although an
annual event
tensions are high ahead of the
presidential ceremony and there were
real fears there'd be clashes
and most of these are ardent trump
supporters still arguing they've been
cheated
and who are going to take some
convincing safety in america
no problem with this this
is what keeps americans safe
this is the challenge for the new
president pulling together
all these disparate groups and the many
militia who are armed
who are feeling suspicious and worried
about the future
alex crawford sky news virginia